and uh to discuss this and so much more
um
on the rich eisen show our friend from
uh pardon india
pardon the interruption espn of course
his long
days with the washington post michael
wilbon back here how are you michael
it's been a rough morning rich rough
morning for those of us who
seem to go from everybody's going from
one unfortunate thing to another but
this you know this is
this is particularly sad while not
surprising you know for those of us who
knew
coach thompson and he was struggling had
some health challenges
not a surprise but sad nonetheless well
then i
greatly appreciate you taking the time
on this day this very morning to
to share with us uh your memories of
john thompson and what
we what we should remember him for
you're the perfect person to set the
stage and
and and set our mindset properly
michael well you know what rich is
interesting because
much of what is going to be said about
john thompson in the next few days
it will be the context of it will be
basketball just like you had and that is
that is the arena in which he
operated i mean you know literally and
figuratively
um because you can go from you know
patrick
before patrick healing and john thompson
got to got to the elite eight before he
ever recruited patrick ewing and then of
course he got the three final fours
lost two of the memorable championship
games of all time won
one by going through akeem olajuwon in
houston and
on down through the allen iverson
episode that was
at the end of john's coaching career
that was the retired 1999.
iverson left in two in 1996 so that's
that's the end of the framing of it
but those of us who were around much
more than that longer than that
uh so many things come to mind i mean
he's the most
fascinating complex person i certainly
ever covered maybe ever met
and i was 21 years old when i got to the
washington post it was a sign to cover
georgetown basketball which was not a
big deal yet
nationally it was locally and uh when i
first started covering the team
john wouldn't speak to me he would not
talk to me
and i laughed about it now i've left
about it for decades
because it was part of john's like
initiation
right of initiation right a passage you
know he would call
like he would call each previous the
writers he knew
so he would call kornheiser and and john
feinstein or
dave kendrick uh and he would say who
was his wilbot who's this
kid from chicago who the hell is he why
should i talk to him right
and then you know five years later he
called me and said who is this mike
freeman who
is david aldridge who's the j.a adande
i'm not talking to him
nice and all of us became so impacted it
so
five years to shorten this a little bit
five years after i got that
treatment um my father
died um at the age of sixty my father
passed away
lung cancer it was on march 11th so it's
right in march madness
i was killing the team coming in
georgetown i didn't
call anybody i found out my father died
which was expected i can rush home i fly
home
i walk into my parents kitchen my
mother's on the phone she's on the phone
what seems to me to be
a long time considering we had stuff to
do we had
affairs to tend to she finally got off
the phone and i said
what why are you on the phone who's that
she said i was talking to coach thompson
and i said what was that about she said
i'm not telling you what it was about
we had we had a great conversation and i
then i go down to the funeral home
and in the funeral home already remind
you i've not called
john or anybody in georgetown i got on a
plane and i flew home
i get to the funeral home the minute i
get out i you know leave my parents
house after i get to o'hare
there's an enormous wreath of flowers
and it says from john thompson
and there's another enormous wreath of
flowers and it says from georgetown
basketball
as if they aren't one in the same and
everybody in washington has stories
about big john you know and i think of
them even as i'm talking
mark asher who covered the team for a
long time
and mark was a character to say the
least his interesting character most of
the people on the post
we at times we just found it so annoying
we couldn't deal with them even though
we loved them
he had a kidney transplant and john
thompson
sat in his hospital room overnight
and you know again people would say well
god hated the media john hated this he
was the most paranoid paranoia
right all these things these phrases
coined and yet you had all these other
things going on
and all of them it could be true at some
point by the way i mean if you talk to
jackie mcmullen she's going to have a
big john story of five
you know um i'll tell you one other
quick one
i one morning he called me at seven
o'clock in the morning and said hey get
get down here
i said coach what are you doing he said
just get down here
so i go down he's sitting in the sedan
in the front of the parking lot
front parking lot and that's as close as
they get in i said coach what are we
doing
we're going to look for a guy named
rachel edmund you can google
rachel edna what you're going to find
essentially is he was a drug lord a drug
kingpin
and he was trying to get at young kids
in washington who included
a freshman maybe a sophomore i think a
freshman named alonzo morning
and big john in a way that
you know you can't even think about
people doing this he just put it out
there
you need to come see me you're not
getting at any of my kids you're not
getting any kids i can protect
but you need to come see me and because
he didn't go see him immediately john
went looking for him we went looking for
him in john's
sedan come on big john's sedan
we're looking at barber shops we're at
church everywhere we're everywhere in
in dc and northeast and southeast
probably in northwest where everywhere
we can go and look for we couldn't find
them
but i remember sitting in the car
thinking i didn't have the nerve to ask
john if we
find him what are we go what are we
doing if we find him right
and this is the length he would go
to protect people that mattered to him
which was a lot of people and
this like i said i have thousands of
those
stories personal professional
about what he meant and you know what
rich not all that many of them are about
basketball
some of them are they're tangentially
related to proposition 48 and 42
and the links he would go to say this is
wrong
to the lens he would stand up to the
ncaa
to school administrators the people he
thought were taking advantage of their
position in life you know yeah i mean i
was around for all those games i was the
beat writer covering the villanova game
i was the i was covering the michael
jordan game
i covered the akeem patrick game
all the chris mullen games the games in
the big east have built the biggies
i covered all that stuff and and yet
the stories i think of they involve
basketball but some of them don't
some of them a lot of them most of them
don't i was talking to coronizer this
morning
our stories they wind up being personal
very personal stories about big john and
who he was
to his core i mean much of what i
believe about education
and athletics comes from i mean i was
shaped
40 years ago on him he didn't have one
in guns
unless they transfer out because they
couldn't take it because he was a
demanding man he was demanding he was
commanding and demanding
you know people think they know about
tough love and all they don't know
anything about that
most of today's players who are one and
guns and in and out of schools and
they're just there to be
you know roasted and and toasted and
they head out they couldn't play for
john thompson
they couldn't attend they couldn't have
signed a letter of intent
so so much of what matters to me today
in his passing the reflection they have
nothing
to do with basketball even though that's
the venue that's the context in which we
view his life
trust me the the people who are around
him the longest
um know that there was so so so much
much more than that michael wilbon here
on the rich eisen show
i i i don't even know how the hell to
follow up
on that michael i mean that was so
beautiful and comprehensive and
engrossing and moving and
wonderful and saddening
all at once like i i i it's dreadful
this is a pandemic this man deserves a
huge
memorial a huge memorial well that's
what probably
saddens me most so there are three
people who have
more than three three men have died in
in
washington life um
during the pandemic and none of the
three were able to be
set off properly um wes
unseld bobby mitchell
and john thompson three hall of fame
people in terms of the the arena of
sports
john multiple halls of fame but
certainly the basketball hall of fame
um bobby mitchell you know the pro
football hall of fame a historic figure
in washington the first black
[ __ ] and i'm using that term
advisedly
and west enfield and and three enormous
figures and
i you know other than my father
i think as an adult man john thompson
maybe a couple of uncles
john thompson had more influence than
anybody else
in my personal life um and
with bobby mitchell and wes um that
that's a that's a large percentage of my
work life
you know just of my life covering
basketball
and football in washington dc for for 30
years from
1980 to 2010 when i left to come to the
network full-time
and but big john it's just um
you know it's just remarkable sort of
who he was how
the voice the size people used to be so
afraid of it i would laugh and he would
say shut up you don't give me away don't
tell people i'm a nice guy
don't tell anybody i'm a softly ruined
my reputation
he um he ran into my then girlfriend
um and she went to virginia and duke law
school and
they met he said young lady come over
let me talk to you
because you you clearly have academic
credentials you are too smart to be
involved with this fool
and my wife's got the biggest kick out
of it
you know we talked about i texted her
this morning she was on a plane not too
long ago when she went up and and big on
her sister i'm talking to my son
uh and just sort of you know getting to
see
you know who he was and i had taken and
i introduced him to him one more time
and i don't even know like how am i
going to tell
my son who big john is who he was
and it's like i said we're all you know
everybody nationally he's a great
basketball coach yes
he put out a brand which redefined
college basketball i'm not trying to
minimize what he did as a coach
he redefined it his defense go look at
any tape of the way defense was played
even by john wooden's ucla teams in the
1970s and look at the way it was played
after 1978
john's teams pre patrick both sleepy
floyd
you know craig shelton john during guys
who played in the nba
but go look at it after that go look at
it with patrick ewing
you could make the case michael you know
michael you could make the case that the
way that
no you could make the case that the way
that the nba started playing in the late
80s that we just saw on the last dance
that georgetown presage that sort of
puts you on your ass type defense the
physical nature you could say that
georgetown ushered in
that documentary which i'm sure you've
seen yes rich you know that
that documentary sort of spells it out
and um
and and and the pro guys you're so right
they were so proud of it i remember when
john was coaching the olympic team and
one of the pre one of the games leading
up to it was played in charlotte
and that charlotte team was like an acc
select team
and on it specifically were michael
jordan mugsy vogues and
um spread lip
and big john said to to michael at one
point hey
i want you to press our guys i want you
to press our guys trap them
put real defense on him and big john's
and michael said no
no coach you don't you don't want us to
do that because we're gonna play it the
way you play it
with our level of skill and talent
it was funny because whoever was on that
select whoever was on that that uh
olympic team at the time the
pre-olympics yeah no the olympic team
they couldn't even get the ball across
half court and jordan jordan
loved that that was sort of testimony
to big john and the way he taught
defense but applied
by by pros real pros in in real time
even though it was a summer and they
hadn't practiced it was an exhibition
and all that
yes yes that that defense
conveyed and that intensity conveyed
and um yeah so there's so there's a ton
of basketball stuff but there's the
far far far better stuff rich trust me
if you
if you read anything by anybody tom
boswell the washington post will
write i know the best possible obituary
um because he covered john in high
school he covered big john
his high school teams and um
but tom boswell i'm just telling people
in advance if you want to read something
go to washingtonpost.com
tomorrow if not tonight and read
whatever tom boswell writes about
about big john and it will be
something that you remember reading for
the rest of your life michael thanks for
the time again
it's it's such a treasure to hear you
talk about a man that meant so much to
you
and it's a treasure for me that you um
you know do it on the day of of this
man's passing it's something i do not
take lightly i greatly appreciate it i
love you
and um let's talk soon about everything
else going on in the sports world
rich love you as well thank you for
having me it is a difficult
uh day but it's probably good like in a
funeral way to talk about it and
um that's what you know so many of us
will do delay nightmare david aldridge
and jaya donde
and people that you have known all your
career that's what we've that's what
we've started doing
uh today and some of some of those
people have passed away stuart scott
brian burwell ralph wiley i mean we were
all
in a fraternity that where you had to
earn you had to earn
time respect attention interviews
you know you had to earn it and and
there was no
easy way through it there was no grading
on the curve
and so that's what all of us are doing
today and like i said it's a
it's a particularly sad day but but
thanks for having me man i appreciate it
right back at you
best to tony and everybody else michael
let's chat soon
thanks again thank you thank you you bet
that's michael wilbon
i'm definitely watching part of the
interruption later that's for darn short